Hey
Deadpool here and this is what I look
like on a pathetic regular screen but
hold on to your balloon not because on
IMAX
I look twice as what is this
no the screen is larger so naturally I'd
be larger to out that great but that's
just great I'm a child actor now and
always ends well
you see Deadpool inglorious
larger-than-life IMAX because bigger is
better
well that's precious
[Music]
oh you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care auditor stronk eyes
beautiful girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in a
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again kiss me like you missed me read
what in the ass
my name's cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid movie guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be he need you lot smarter
than I look
I am lettin cable kill this kid I can't
do this alone
we're gonna form a super-duper group
that's what we're gonna be
forward-thinking gender-neutral you will
be known as x-force isn't that a little
derivative you're absolutely right now
cue the music
tell me they got that in slow motion
you're the right thing is messy you want
to fight for what's right that is why
the man bun is just a millennial mullet
oh god I wish I finished college it
lives up to the hype
plus plus they probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it
[Music]